[Applaudissements]
bonjour
je m'appelle olivia putman je suis
designer alors si on voulait me
caricaturer on vous raconterai que de
nombreuses personnalités du monde de
l'art et du design ont jalonné mon
parcours mais quasiment exclusivement ça
c'est pour la page wikipédia aujourd'hui
moi j'ai envie de penser à toutes les
personnes qui ont compté qu'ils
resteront anonymes à des moments anodins
qui sont finalement devenus décisif et à
la rencontre avec des objets qui nous
fait rêver comme ceux que je repérais
par exemple pour ma mère quand j'étais
petit et qu elle m'envoyait en
éclaireuse dans les allées des puces
pour repérer les objets bleus dont elle
faisait la collection
parce que pour moi le design c'est une
histoire de rencontre j'ai une
conviction absolue
l'inspiration vient de la somme de
rencontres d'expérience que vous avez pu
avoir
alors j'ai eu la chance d'avoir
plusieurs vies professionnelles qui
m'ont permis d'acquérir plein
d'expérience plein de vision est
évidemment plein de rencontres alors la
première des rencontres que j'ai fait
c'est évidemment celle que j'ai fait
avec ma mère alors ma mère andrée putman
c'était une femme incroyable elle est
devenue icône du design malgré elle
c'était le genre de mère à vous amener
voir un concert des pink floyd
quand vous avez cinq ans travaillé seize
heures par jour transformez vos vacances
scolaires en visite de chantier et quand
elle me croisaient au palace et que
j'avais 14 ans alors pour ceux qui
savent pas ce qu'est la boîte de nuit
des années 80 le seul mot qu'elle avait
le lendemain c'était ma chérie j'espère
que tu t'es bien amusé
alors plus qu'une éducation c'est une
vision du monde qu'elle m'a offert et
comme un long fil conducteur
j'ai retenu une leçon faire de chaque
rencontre une inspiration à la sorbonne
dans les années 80 j'ai fait une licence
d'histoire de l'art j'ai adoré jongler
entre l'impact la peinture chinoise
l'art gothique
mais c'est la rencontre avec des
personnes qui m'ont poussé à quitter la
fac pour créer une association usine
éphémère qui allait récupérer des
endroits abandonnées et les transformer
en ateliers d'artistes
alors on a transformé une usine de
boutons un hôpital en centre d'art
alors c'était amusant il faut imaginer
la salle d'expo dans l'ancien bloc
opératoire et c'était merveilleux
c'était mon premier cdi et la
possibilité de faire de l' architecture
tout en restant hors du cadre
moi je suis convaincu que l'adn de la
création va venir de cette somme de
choses que j'évoquais précédemment
la première fois que j'ai endossé le
costume de designers c'était pour
nespresso une marque que vous connaissez
tous
il lance un concours international pour
imaginer leur nouvelle tasse alors face
au casting typiquement c'est un projet
dans lequel on peut être pétrifiée moi
j'ai décidé de l'accepter comme un défi
cd projet merveilleux parce qu'on sait
que votre création
si vous êtes retenu va être entre les
mains de tat de personnes et j'ai décidé
de revenir à mon vécu
moi j'ai toujours été passionné par les
personnes j'aime regarder les gens et
devant ma page blanche je me suis
souvenu d'une scène je suis assise à une
terrasse de café et je vois un serveur
qui courent est évidemment la tâche se
renverse je pense que tout le monde a
déjà vécu une scène comme ça et je me
suis dit première idée pourquoi ne pas
offrir une tasse adapté aux serveurs
parce qu'ils vont de toute façon
toujours courir donc j'ai travaillé sur
l'ergonomie de la tasse
et ensuite deuxième idée mais c'est
évidemment en regardant cet objet un la
capsule
quand même un objet remarquable très
bien dessinés qui devenu l'emblème de la
marque en moi ce que je trouve en plus
fascinant c'est qu'au fond on a mis du
café dans une capsule et on en a fait
quasiment un acte sociologique
aujourd'hui c'est les chefs d'entreprise
les avocats qui vous propose de faire un
café avant ils demandaient à des
assistantes à d donc j'ai eu envie de
faire un hommage à cette innovation qui
a changé le rapport de ces réunions rang
dans des moments plus conviviaux plus
plus sympathique et j'ai pris la capsule
est gelée juste transformer entassées
comme vous pouvez voir ça fait une tasse
alors sa base biseautés a été une
aubaine pour moi puisqu'elle a permis
d'un briquet la tasse dans la soucoupe
vous savez quoi
c'est merveilleux me l'ont adoré j'ai
été retenu et c'est comme ça que mon
dessin s'est retrouvé entre les mains de
millions de personnes de sao paulo à
tokyo
ce qui est incroyable quand on dessine
un objet c'est finalement de le
retrouver par hasard sur sa route
parce que dessiner un objet s'est jeté
une bouteille à la mer un cc vous c'est
les utilisateurs qui décideront de son
destin et finalement les idées les plus
basiques sont souvent les plus justes
alors je ne peux pas ne pas évoquer une
relève un travail que ma mère a fait
pour christofle pour une collection de
bijoux elle a pris un anneau et elle l'a
simplement tordu et depuis l'an 2000
c'est resté le best-seller de la maison
donc on ne rencontre pas que des
personnes on rencontre des marques des
histoires mais aussi des savoir faire
quand j'ai eu la chance de travailler
pour la lique alors la ligue c'est une
merveilleuse maison de cristal où chaque
objet va être une ode au travail de
chaque ouvrier arrivé comme directrice
artistique là bas c'était pas évident
parce que je voulais amener de
l'innovation respecter la tradition et
je leur ai proposé de faire une
collection de luminaires
alors pour me former g
voulu passer du temps dans la
manufacture échanger avec les différents
ouvriers sur ses savoir-faire assez
complexe et c'est au cours d'une de ces
visites que j'ai repéré comme abandonnés
dans un point mis au rebut une pièce
détachée que j'ai trouvé merveilleuse et
à la manière de mai usine désaffectée
cet objet m'a inspiré j'ai décidé d'en
faire le centre de ma création
alors il ya moi c'est vrai qu'on va vous
dire en design on va pas me raconter
qu'ils rencontrent ça remplace la
technicité du métier les notions il ya
des notions de deux matériaux de
techniques des tas de choses à apprendre
moi j'apprends en fait je vais vous
l'avouer tous les jours et j'adore
apprendre alors par exemple j'ai repris
des études pour devenir paysagiste
pendant mon aventure de jeunesse dans
l'art contemporain et c'était
merveilleux alors là j'ai appris tous
les noms de fleurs et d'arbres mon latin
or c'est drôle parce qu'on dit souvent
le latin une langue morte
mais en fait elle est absolument
internationale quand il s'agit d'aller
désigner les végétaux aux quatre coins
du monde et donc surtout être paysagiste
c'est accepter de jouer avec des tas de
contraintes
si vous avez un ami qui veut un baobab
dans son jardin à côté de lyon il faudra
juste lui expliquer que c'est pas
possible
et donc ces contraintes en fait c'est
intéressant parce que si le design est
un monde de liberté d'ouverture c'est un
monde où il va falloir accepter beaucoup
beaucoup de contraintes
et c'est dans cet esprit que j'ai
réalisé une collection de mobilier pour
mettre points comme avec une contrainte
très particulière sur laquelle on a
travaillé avec mes équipes qui étaient
le panier moyen la personne qui va sur
son ordinateur pour acheter du mobilier
j'ai respecté le coup la production etc
et j'ai réussi à imaginer cette
collection mobile
et simple raffiné à prix abordable parce
que si les contraintes n'existait pas on
n'aurait pas ce cadre et je pense que
c'est important d'avoir un cadre dans
lequel on va pouvoir exprimer cette
liberté alors quand on dessine des lieux
aussi on a beaucoup de contraintes
quand j'aménage un lieu il ya un
programme avec des contraintes d'espacé
usage de chaque pièce alors un jour j'ai
aménagé un immeuble de bureaux sur les
champs-elysées hélas le programme était
assez particulier puisque c'étaient des
salles de réunion mais alors des salles
de réunions à tous les étages en
pagaille et une fois de plus j'ai décidé
de repartir de mon vécu et je me suis
dit nous font on a tous vécu des
réunions interminables
alors pourquoi pas pensé au confort
pourquoi pas pensé à offrir un lieu où
il serait bon être j'en ai parlé au
président de cette fédération et je vais
proposer de dessiner un club alors
pardon ap un club où on va danser mais
un club où on va se réunir différemment
on est plus mal installé sur une chaise
inconfortable dans une salle lugubre
mais confortablement installé dans un
canapé à dos et un bar
bref récemment il me disait encore que
c'est la salle où il ya le plus des
changes la qualité des échanges en fête
a été a été amélioré par les postures et
je pense que c'est intéressant de voir
finalement que le design peut aussi
permettre de changer la vie quotidienne
des personnes
j'ai la chance de voyager aussi pour mon
travail ce qui me permet d'aller droit
au but dans certains pays découvrir des
cultures découvrir des traditions
découvrir des goûts des visions du monde
moi ce que j'aime c'est le design du
métissage celui qui va allier les
cultures et je me souviens de cette
rencontre complètement improbable dans
une ferme au chili je dessinais un
lounge à santiago avec un tisseur en
fait un tisseur de tapis et de nos
échanges complètement dingue pour
arriver à obtenir un dessin qui réunit
ray nos deux cultures
donc voilà quelques éléments de ma
croisée des chemins qui sont surtout des
rencontres parce que bon je crois que
voulait compris hein j'ai repris
l'entreprise familiale sans que ce soit
mon destin l'agencé andrée putman est
comme ça devenu depuis dix ans quasiment
aujourd'hui le studio putman en moi je
n'avais pas du tout envie d'être la
fille de mes une folle envie d'accepter
ça un nouveau défi qu'est créé cette
proposition que ma mère me faisait elle
avait 84 ans elle travaillait encore et
elle m'a dit serait temps de venir quand
même chez nous
c'est un jour extraordinaire parce que
j'ai eu ce sentiment merveilleux d'être
à ma place comme si tout ce que j'avais
fait précédemment elle aime servir à
diriger ce studio reconnue
internationalement
parce que c'est c'est en m'ouvrant eaux
montent en accumulant des expériences
moi je suis en formation continue
permanente et j'ai envie de dire que
quels que soient nos formations peut un
jour accepter de changer de voie
imaginer que ce soit encore possible il
faut ouvrir les yeux
ouvrir les oreilles et accepter des
défis est le dernier d'entre eux m'a
c'était d'être là avec vous pour me
raconter en 12 minutes merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]